what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
video by alexander grace
titled if she fails this test dump her
so i'm just genuinely curious like what
what like test this is but before i
start do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification
bell um that way you're going to be
notified
of my daily videos and as you guys know
i'm trying to hit 20 000 subscribers and
each and every one of you helps me get
to that goal
okay let me make sure that this isn't
okay a friend
should be happy to do you favors she
should be
happy to inconvenience herself if it
means
helping you out because it means that
she views the two of you
as a team she is committed to you
your success is her success she's not
involved in all that pettiness of
keeping score
keeping track of you know who gives more
in the relationship who takes more all
that tallying nonsense
if your girlfriend thinks it is beneath
her to help you
to support you to do you favors then
dump her trust me you're better off in
the long run there is a radical branch
of extreme feminism that takes the idea
of
female empowerment and independence to
absolutely
ludicrous levels where they think that
doing anything that supports a man you
know cooking him meals doing him favors
helping him out
that is toxic patriarchy that is
demeaning work
women have been serving men for
thousands of years no okay i actually
agree with that
like if you're dating somebody that
doesn't want to help you
or isn't like generous and isn't like
kind
like i don't know that's kind of like
common sense to me don't date them
why can't he do you favors why can't he
cook a meal for you blah blah blah
of course men should be doing their
girlfriend's favors they should be
supporting them but that's my point
it is the hallmark of a high quality
person that they are happy to help out
their partner
regardless of gender how much a woman is
happy to support you
is a strong indicator of how committed
she is to the relationship and to you
take your career i wouldn't say that
like most people that i know that are
generally
like not kind it's not specific to you
it's just
like in general they're not kind people
um
but yeah no i agree i feel like this is
just common sense like don't date
somebody that's not helpful
not generous not kind here for example
now if she truly believes that the
relationship is going to last
she loves you she wants to spend her
life with you she's happy with her
choice
one day she wants to have children with
you then she's not going to view it as
you know
your career it's just your life and by
extension it's her life as well
there may be times when you have to move
state move
cities in order to pursue better
financial opportunities when it comes to
your job
pay close attention to how she reacts in
those situations
if she gets all righteous and indignant
saying things like well why should i
have to move for you
for your career that's a big red flag
she's not thinking of you in the long
term she's not thinking of the two of
you as a unit
as a team she's thinking of herself as
an
independent entity and how this move is
going to affect her
personally she's looking out for her own
selfish interests
now obviously if she's committed to the
relationship that doesn't mean that
she's automatically going to move cities
and go along with everything that you
say but pay attention to the words that
a woman is using and how she interprets
this information
is she thinking about the both of you
and your relationship or is she only
thinking about herself but this
principle of support is really broad it
doesn't just relate to the career it's
about whether or not she is
supporting you as a man as a person is
she invested in you
does she want you to succeed does she
want you to achieve your goals
does she want you to be happy toxic
low quality women take take take they
just think of men
as a resource to be exploited what can i
get from this man how can i suck him
of all of his emotional and financial
energy suck him dry and then leave him
move on to someone else but a high
quality woman is not that
and that's what i say if a girl is
asking you to buy
stuff that you clearly can't afford like
she's clearly not in it for the right
reasons because any girl that actually
is into you isn't gonna
ask you to buy things that you like
obviously can't afford
short term in her thinking she realizes
that
as your partner when you succeed she
succeeds
when you're happy she's happy and so
she's happy to invest
in you and in your relationship because
she knows in the long term
i'm just confused what's the test like
so far he's just been kind of saying
things that to me are common sense i'm
just curious what the test is the
benefits are going to accrue
to her with that kind of thinking a high
quality woman is excited to help you
she's excited to do you favors
she's enthusiastic about doing whatever
she can to make your life easier
sometimes it's just small things like
maybe she sees that you're getting
a bit stressed with all of your
responsibilities and so she volunteers
to do some small things to just
you know make your life a little bit
more simple take that responsibility off
maybe she cleans your apartment maybe
she cooks you dinner maybe she gives you
a massage or sometimes it's bigger like
maybe if she senses that your stress is
getting too much
she volunteers to move to a smaller
house with lesser rent so that you can
reduce your work hours have a better
work life balance and focus on your more
emotional spiritual goals focus on your
hobbies just be a happier person
you see it's not all financial not at
all what's important is that she's
invested in
you you specifically whatever your goals
are and she's happy
to help in whatever way she can that's
what you're looking for and you can
actually test this out
really early on in the dating process to
find out if a woman
is interested in you in the long term if
she's committed or if she's just looking
to
boost her own short-term selfish
interests now back when i was a much
younger man in my early 20s
me and my buddies were you know out
practicing the pickup artist stuff
practicing social skills
we learned about this concept dating
coaches would call it a compliance test
and it's something you do
in the middle of a like a flirtatious
interaction it's still relevant today so
i'm going to explain how it works
what you do is in the middle of flirting
with a woman you make a small
seemingly insignificant request hey can
you pass me that napkin
oh could you move over here with me so i
can hear you better oh would you mind
holding my drink while i go and get my
coat you see they are these
small insignificant favors symbolic
almost but
psychologically they can be very very
telling because if she is willing to
inconvenience herself simply because
you requested that of her you asked her
that favor it means
she likes you she's invested you know
she's passed that compliance test and
she wants to get to know you better she
wants to make a positive impression it's
a good way of
do you guys really think that asking a
girl to like
move tables or like hand you a napkin
is gonna be that telling of her
character i don't know maybe confirming
how you're doing right like is the
flirting going well am i building
attraction you know you give her this
test
but it also is quite effective at
generating attraction because
you trigger that backwards
rationalization process because as
humans we know we only really
do favors for people that we are
somewhat invested in and so if she
does this compliance test and she does
what you ask her to do even if it's
something small like hey can you move
over here for a second
she's gonna backwards rationalize that
like i would only do a favor for
somebody that i liked
i guess i like this guy let's explore
this further now there's more to it of
course compliance tests can be a little
bit complex but it's not really in the
purview of this video so
if you have any follow-up questions just
hit me up on hey heroes send me
you know your questions tell me a story
i'll send you a personalized video in
response but the thing is when it comes
to a girl that you're already dating you
don't really need a compliance test
to confirm that she's attracted to you
because the fact that she's dating you
shows that she's attracted you need
something that's a little bit more
deeper you know something that we'll
call
a commitment test now i wouldn't
recommend creating artificial
situations just to test a woman just pay
attention what's going on in your life
and don't be afraid to ask her to do
things for you would you mind doing the
dishes tonight
i ripped my sweater would you mind
sewing it up for me i've been invited to
this party and they've asked me to bring
a plate of food would you mind creating
something
they can even be financial requests like
if the two of you pull up at a gas
station
you can ask her hey while i fill up the
car can you go inside and pay
i know it seems like it's just something
small and practical but i'm telling you
there's massive psychological meaning in
how she responds to that
if she gets all righteous and upset like
why should i do that for you there's a
problem if she's happy to do it like oh
great
are there girls that like react to small
like that small of favors like that's
not even that big of a favor
huh i mean you guys have told me more on
this channel about like
dating as a guy than i've ever really
thought about but that's just kind of
nuts to me
that someone like i can't imagine
someone over the age of like 21
or like over the age of 21
reacting that way especially to someone
they're dating
huh this is just interesting an
opportunity to make your life easier to
do something for you
that's a good sign she's committed to
you she likes you she wants the
relationship
to succeed and she's working towards
that again let me emphasize this is not
about male dominance and like
training women to be submissive to men's
power or anything like that this is
about teamwork it's about a natural
reciprocity that should exist in a
relationship
where you're helping each other out
because you're committed for those high
quality women who watch this channel the
exact same principle operates in reverse
if your boyfriend
refuses to do anything nice for you
doesn't want to do you any favors
that's a problem if he doesn't pick you
up at the airport if he doesn't
you know go with you to your cousin's
wedding or cook you a meal every now and
then it means that he's not viewing the
two of you as a team
he's still thinking of himself as an
independent unit that's a problem
relationships where people are keeping
score do not work
they don't you know if there's so much
energy that goes into
keeping track of who's giving more and
who's receiving more and arguing and
fighting over who's getting the better
deal
it's exhausting and it's childish if
you're with a woman like that
dump her find somebody else find a woman
who's happy to do you a favor because
when she's in a relationship with you
she doesn't even view it as a favor
because she's not thinking in terms of
individual entities she's happy to
work to support the relationship that's
the beauty of a relationship between two
high-quality people
they're both so generous to each other
that there's an
abundance of love and energy and good
will to that's actually
that reminds me of my parents a lot
because they both like literally do so
much for each other like
i remember when i was a kid like my dad
would like carry my mom
like we were outside like i don't know
what it was it was like a funeral or
something
and my dad would like literally carry my
mom so she didn't have to like walk in
her heels in the grass
and then like my mom's also done like
similar stuff where she's like
like she cooks for my dad every day and
literally has always picked up after him
so no i think what he's saying is
definitely
true um from what i've seen like from my
parents
go around you don't need to keep score
because both people's
needs are being taken care of there's no
sense of lack there's no need to be
protective
of your own interests you don't need to
be selfish like that in your outlook so
the next time you're dating a girl give
her a commitment test
find out early is she invested in you
does she want the relationship to
succeed
ask her to do some small favors for you
and if her response is like
you do it i'm not doing that dumper
when it okay i'm not sure that the
napkin
test is gonna be a big enough
like commitment test or like moving a
table
like i i don't know about that but i
could see what he's saying
um like definitely about like you can't
be keeping score
about stuff like that but let me know in
the comments if you guys agree
or you disagree and let me know what
like three things that you guys think
are the key to a healthy relationship
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel i'm trying to hit 20 000
subscribers and each and every one of
you helps
and while you're at it ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily
videos